story in five words
[Music]
people find good in villains
that was pretty good right Julie that's
the story people are hardwired to love
movie villains according to this new
study and they want to see their good
side and maybe see the bad side in the
protagonist does that surprise you no
not at all nobody likes a nice guy
you're laughing why is that you're
married right yeah yeah yeah currently
where I was when I left okay well no I'm
just saying I mean like I think that
most people enjoy a bad guy right yes
and it also is interesting because it
says a lot about the people that like
the bad guys the article says people who
like movie villains are more likely to
be villainous themselves which was
really deep for me I read about that
earlier yeah go to therapy on Monday
we all have that we sympathize but maybe
because they're always petting kittens
and things like that Charlie no I don't
think it's that I but I I thought it was
really fascinating the study I always
thought it was like an American thing we
like Jesse James we like you know Bonnie
and Clyde Hannibal Lecter that it was
sort of an American thing but apparently
it's not it's a fairly Universal thing
but you know it's kind of interesting
nobody wants to be Bernie Madoff people
really hate Bernie van or SPF nobody
like there's nobody looks at him and
said I mean he had he he stole billions
of dollars or allegedly yeah but nobody
is sitting back going man I wish I was
that guy yeah you'll be the only person
clamoring to be to play him in the movie
whereas Jeffrey Dahmer has people
falling out of the woodwork to play him
oh my God and that show is amazing I'm
obsessed with have you seen it I have
not seen it but it's definitely on my
list after the dinner bomber the I mean
it's true that nobody wants to play like
a financial scammer or something like
that but they like these evil guys who
want to rule the world because they're
striving for something right yeah and
and uh Julie's right women love the bad
boy yeah they do they what
you're still single
let's move on I have other points to
make here I I often I often relate to
the villains like Jaws I mean we were
treating him like he was the bad guy we
were swimming in his soup and when they
say we need a bigger boat that's fat
shaming
and and Biff Tannen I mean he's living
with his grandmother he might be an
orphan and he gets a time machine use it
to win bets and to to murder his high
school crush his husband
I do that
you know what I mean it may be true
Molly is it in our modern world these
villains are kind of victims right they
always have a grievance against someone
and we live in a victim culture am I
onto something here I mean it's a good
theory but I my problem with this I'm
Lutheran so I believe all people are
sinful all people are bad guys isn't the
bigger problem that people like have
trouble understanding that supposedly
good people are evil and I think about
this because like we just had an
election and every single person who ran
for re-election was re-elected like our
problem is that we don't see we don't we
don't understand that these like
supposedly good people are actually evil
that's right and we always say throw the
bums out and then we don't throw them
out
I think I I felt bad for Voldemort
because he had no nose the guy had no
nose
can you imagine if Joe Biden had had no
news what would he do I know I mean it's
just it's a certain
certain look all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else